Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic.
And since it's very creation, the internet has opened the doors for so many possibilities.
Jobs, entertainment, forums, the social media, the internet has no doubt changed the world.
Yet, out of all these possibilities, there is one undeniable fact that will always remain the same.
The internet is full of pricks.
Complainers, trolls, people who live to force their opinion onto your opinion
whether they have any idea what they're talking about or not,
they're pretty pathetic.
And they show no sign of going away any time soon.
And there's just so many of these goddamn idiots that it's hard to properly deal with them
in the best way possible.
Why insult these brainless dimwits, when we would be proud to insult them for you.
Channel Awesome and Blip proudly present: "eSults".
Video responses for when you just don't have time to deal with these mental three year olds.
We have video responses for whiners
Whiner: "That Capwin guy, he doesn't play as Goku."
NC: "I'm sorry, I'm having a real hard time
Whiner: "And you know what *continues to whine unintelligibly."
NC: "Understanding you. Umm, here's someone who better speaks your language."
*Babies cries uncontrollably*
Whiner: "Hey!"
Responses for ramblers who just need more attention.
Rambler: "You're so stupid. I bet you don't even know what puberty is."
Rachel: "Yeah..."
Rambler: "Have you hit puberty yet? Idiot!"
Rachel: "You don't say! You are so smart."
Rambler: "Screw everyone!"
Rachel: "God, you're better than me."
Rachel: "Please, tell me more."
Everything you need when you just don't have the energy to listen to any more insecure morons.
NC: "The next time you try to say something smart, let me know, because I gotta record it on my iPhone."
NC: "You're so adorable."
Locate them at Blip's YouTube channel and start using them today.
Because by God, you have a life to live and-
*Offscreen* I hate everything! You know what I hate? Microsoft too!
They don't.
*Offscreen* And Sony! Linux is where it's at.
*Offscreen* Leave's a pretty good show, but you know what, screw them!